[Music]
all around the world holocaust memorial
day is being marked at services across
europe many reduced to tears at this
memorial faces of survivors most of whom
are now in their 90s are part of an
exhibit commissioned by britain's prince
charles
what better way of
rejecting that kind of philosophy that
led to the holocaust and honoring
survivors from this project
holocaust memorial day also remembers
people killed in genocide that followed
in cambodia rwanda bosnia and darfur
and as the world honors international
holocaust remembrance day one local
resident is reminding us why this dark
period in history is still so relevant
as christian casares reports she's also
sharing her concern about teaching the
younger generations
this is the anniversary of the
liberation of auschwitz really
significant
because it's focusing on
liberation
the end of the holocaust
susan dublin oversees the sperling
kronberg mack holocaust remembrance
center in summerlin and says it's
imperative that we as a community never
forget the stark moment in time the
first thing that people always are drawn
to is the teapot from schindler's
factory holocaust impacted the entire
world most people don't realize that it
wasn't just germany it wasn't just
eastern europe it was throughout the
world on the walls are the faces of some
of the survivors in southern nevada who
are slowly passing on dublin says less
than 100 are still alive and covet now
taking lives
the center also honoring survivors who
have passed away with this garden
memorial the stones are original pieces
from the roads many families had to
travel back
might be doomed to repeat them christian
casa is live local now